Here we have a gruesome problem. Although the title
is a bit menacing, all we're really going to do is
color words. Sounds like fun. So, we're going to use two
colors to start out with, blue and green. Now, we
say a word is blue if a lower case
b occurs before a lower case t within the word.
We say a word is green if a lower case
g occurs after the occurrence of a lower case t.
Within the word. So an example of a blue
word would be wombat, because we have a lowercase
b, occurring before lowercase t. As an example of
a green word, we have racketeering, because g occurs after
the current lowercase t. As one last example, we
have the word abating, which is blue, because b occurs
before t. And green because g occurs after t.
So, yes, one word can be both blue and green.
And, lastly, we just find a new color. I will
call is grue. It may look like some purplish-pink. But,
it's a brand new color that you've never seen before
because I say so. I word is grue if it's
blue or green. And it can be both blue and
green and still be grue. So all three of the
words I used here are grue. So those are our
gruesome words and we've been asked to identify all the grue
words within a given string. And we're going to
use our regular expressions skills to do that. So what
is a regular expression going to look like? My basic
strategy is going to write it like this. Where I'm
going to define what a blue word is like
and a green word is like and match both words
using the regular expression or operator. So first let's look
at blue. Here I have the regex for blue words.
We have zero more characters followed by a lower case b.
And in between the B and the T can be zero
more characters, and after the B and the T can be
zero more characters. We're going to do the same thing with green. Here
I have a T and a G with zero more characters
before and after and in between. So, here I have a solution
to the problem. I import the regular expression library, and then
I just use re dot find all, with the completed regular expression.
First we identify. Blue words and then afterwards we do the green words
and we just feed in the string that we passed into the function.